Alright, so I want to relate my band object to my stage object.
>> Right.
>> So I'm guessing I'm going to drag either look up or master detail.
>> Yep.
>> And I know we're into some trouble
with that earlier so, which one should I use?
>> There's are a lot of differences between the look up and the
master detail, but one of the core differences, is that a look up
relationship is not a required field
whereas with the master detail, its automatically
required. And since, in the case of our schema, a band might necessarily
be created without already being booked, to a
stage or scheduled for a stage, so we'd want
to choose look-up in that case, so it doesn't
require that field when you create a band record.
>> Okay.